we'll note the name of the senator who
has just taken the oath and will present
the oath book to him for signature the
sergeant-at-arms will make the
proclamation here do you hear ye hear ye
all persons are commanded to keep silent
on pain of imprisonment while the Senate
of the United States is sitting for the
trial of the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the House of
Representatives against Donald John
Trump President of the United States
recognized I'd like to state that for
the information of all senators the
trial briefs filed yesterday by the
parties have been printed and are now at
each senators desk the following
documents will be submitted to the
Senate for printing in the Senate
Journal the precept issued January 16
2020 the writ of summons issued on
January 16 2020 and the receipt of
summons dated January 16 2020 the
following documents which were received
by the Secretary of the Senate will be
submitted to the Senate for printing in
the Senate Journal pursuant to the order
of January 16 2020 the answer of Donald
John Trump president of the United
States to the articles of impeachment
exhibited by the House of
Representatives against him On January
16 2020 received by the Secretary of the
Senate on January 18 2020 the trial
brief filed by the House of
Representatives received by the
Secretary of the Senate on January 18
2020
the trial brief filed by the president
received by the Secretary of the Senate
on January 20 2020 the replication of
the House of Representatives received by
the Secretary of the Senate on January
20 20 20 and the rebuttal brief filed by
the House
of Representatives received by the
Secretary of the Senate on January 21
2020 without objection the foregoing
documents will be printed in the
Congressional Record I note the presence
in the house of the Senate in the chain
in the Senate chamber of the managers on
the part of the House of Representatives
and counsel for the President of the
United States mr. Chief Justice the
majority leader is recognized I send to
the desk a list of floor privileges or
closed sessions it's been agreed to by
both sides is that it be inserted in the
record and agreed to by unanimous
consent without objection
but the further information of all
senators I'm about to send a resolution
to the desk providing for an outline of
the next steps in these proceedings it
will be debatable by parties for two
hours equally divided
Senator Schumer will then send an
amendment to the resolution to the desk
once that amendment has been offered and
reported we'll have a brief recess when
we reconvene Senator Schumer's amendment
will be debatable by the parties for two
hours upon the use or yielding back of
time I intend to move to table Senator
Schumer's amendment and so mr. Chief
Justice I send a resolution to the desk
and ask that it be read the clerk will
read the resolution Senate resolution
483 to provide for related procedures
concerning the articles of impeachment
against Donald John Trump President of
the United States resolved that the
House of Representatives shall file its
record with the Secretary of the Senate
which will consist of those publicly
available materials that have been
submitted to or produced by the House
Judiciary Committee including
transcripts of public hearings or
markups in any materials printed by the
House of Representatives or the House
Judiciary Committee pursuant to House
Resolution 661 the record will be
admitted into evidence subject to any
hearsay evidentiary or other objections
that the President may May
after opening presentations are
concluded all materials filed pursuant
to this paragraph shall be printed and
made available to all parties the
president in the House of
Representatives shall have until 9:00
a.m. on Wednesday January 22nd 2020 to
file any motions permitted under the
rules of impeachment with the exception
of motions to subpoena witnesses or
documents or any other evidentiary
motions responses to any such motions
shall be filed no later than 11:00 a.m.
on Wednesday January 22nd 2020 all
materials filed pursuant to this
paragraph shall be filed with the
secretary and be printed and made
available to all parties arguments on
such motions shall begin at 1:00 p.m. on
Wednesday January 22nd 2020 and each
side may determine the number of persons
to make its presentation following which
the Senate shall deliberate if so
ordered under the impeachment rules and
vote on any such motions following the
disposition of such motions or if no
motions are made then the House of
Representatives shall make its
presentation in support of the articles
of impeachment for a period of time not
to exceed 24 hours over up to three
session days following the House of
Representatives presentation the
president shall make his presentation
for a period not to exceed 24 hours over
up to three session days each side may
determine the number of persons to make
its presentation upon the conclusion of
the president's presentation senators
may question the parties for a period of
time not to exceed 16 hours upon the
conclusion of questioning by the Senate
there shall be four hours of argument by
the parties equally divided followed by
deliberation by the Senate if so ordered
under the impeachment rules on the
question of whether it shall be in order
to consider and debate under the
impeachment rules any motion to subpoena
witnesses or documents the Senate
without any intervening action motion or
amendment so then decide by the yeas and
nays
whether it shall be in order to consider
and debate under the impeachment rules
any motion to subpoena witnesses or
documents following the disposition of
that question other motions provided
under the impeachment rules shall be in
order if the Senate agrees to allow
either the House of Representatives or
the President to subpoena witnesses the
witnesses shall first be deposed and the
Senate shall decide after deposition
which witnesses shall testify pursuant
to the impeachment rules no testimony
shall be admissible in the Senate unless
the parties have had an opportunity to
depose such witnesses at the conclusion
of deliberations by the Senate the
Senate shall vote on each article of
impeachment the resolution is arguable
by the parties for two hours equally
divided mr. manager Schiff are you a
proponent or opponent of this motion
Thank You mr. sip alone are you
a proponent or opponent of the motion
and mr. sip Aloni your side may proceed
first and we'll be able to reserve
rebuttal time if you wish Thank You mr.
chief justice
Majority Leader McConnell Democratic
leader Schumer senators my name is Pat
Cipollone II I'm here as counsel to the
President of the United States our team
is proud to be here representing
President Trump we support this
resolution it is a fair way to proceed
with this trial it is modeled on the
Clinton resolution which had a hundred
senators supporting it the last time
this body considered an impeachment
it requires the house managers to stand
up and make their opening statement and
make their case
they have delayed bringing this
impeachment to this house for 33 days 33
days to this body in it's time to start
with this trial it's a fair process they
will have the opportunity to stand up
and make their opening statement they
will get 24 hours to do that then the
president's attorneys will have a chance
to respond after that all of you will
have 16 hours to ask whatever questions
you have of either side once that's
finished and you have all of that
information we will proceed to the
question of witnesses and some of the
more difficult questions that will come
before this body we are in favor of this
we believe that once you hear those
initial presentations the only
conclusion will be that the president
has done absolutely nothing wrong
and that these articles of impeachment
do not begin to approach the standard
required by the Constitution and in fact
they themselves will establish nothing
beyond those articles you look at those
articles alone and you will determine
that there is absolutely no case
so we respectfully ask you to adopt this
resolution so that we can begin with
this process it is long past time to
start this proceeding and we are here
today to do it and we hope that the
house managers will agree with us and
begin this proceeding today we reserve
the remainder of our time for rebuttal
[Music]
mr. chief justice senators and counsel
for the president house managers on
behalf of the House of Representatives
rise in opposition to leader McConnell's
resolution let me begin by summarizing
why last week we came before you to
present the articles of impeachment
against the president United States for
only the third time in our history those
articles charged President Donald John
Trump with abuse of power and
obstruction of Congress the misconduct
set out in those articles is the most
serious ever charged against a president
the first article abuse of power charges
the president was soliciting a foreign
power to help him cheat in the next
election more overt alleges and we will
prove that he sought to coerce Ukraine
into helping him cheat by withholding
official acts two official acts a
meeting that the new president of
Ukraine desperately sought with
President Trump at the White House to
show the world and the Russians in
particular that the Ukrainian President
had a good relationship with his most
important patron the president of the
United States and even more perniciously
president Trump illegally withheld
almost 400 million dollars in
taxpayer-funded military assistance to
Ukraine a nation at war with our Russian
adversary to compel Ukraine to help him
cheat in the election
astonishingly the president's trial
brief filed yesterday contends that even
if this conduct is proved that there is
nothing that the house or this Senate
may do about it
it is the presence apparent belief that
under Article two he can do anything he
wants no matter how corrupt outfitted in
gaudy legal clothing and yet when the
founders wrote the impeachment clause
they had precisely this type of
misconduct in mind conduct that abuses
the power of his office for personal
benefit that undermines our national
security that invites foreign
interference in our democratic process
of an election
it is the trifecta of constitutional
misconduct justifying impeachment in
article 2 the president is charged with
other misconduct that would likewise
have alarmed the founders the full
complete and absolute obstruction of a
co-equal branch of government the
Congress during the course of its
impeachment investigation into the
president's own misconduct this is every
bit as destructive of our constitutional
order as the misconduct charged in the
first article if a president can
obstruct his own investigation if he can
effectively nullify a power the
Constitution gives solely to Congress
indeed the ultimate power the ultimate
power the Constitution gives to prevent
presidential misconduct then the
president places himself beyond
accountability above the law cannot be
indicted cannot be impeached it makes
him a monarch the very evil against
which our Constitution and the balance
of powers it carefully laid-out was
designed to guard against shortly the
trial these charges will begin and when
it has concluded you'll be asked to make
several determinations did the house
prove that the president abused his
power by seeking to coerce a foreign
nation to help him cheat in the next
election and did he obstruct the
Congress in its investigation into his
own misconduct by ordering his agencies
and officers to cooperate refused to
cooperate in any way to refuse to
testify to refuse to answer subpoenas
for documents and through every other
means and if the house has proved its
case and we believe the evidence will
not be seriously contested you will have
to answer at least one other critical
question does the Commission of these
high crimes and misdemeanors require the
conviction and removal of the president
we believe that it does and that the
Constitution requires that it be so or
the power of impeachment must be deemed
a relic or a casualty to partisan times
and the American people left unprotected
that against a president who would abuse
his power for the very purpose of
corrupting the only other method of
accountability our elections themselves
and so you will vote to find the
president guilty or not guilty
to find his conduct impeachable or not
impeachable but I would submit to you
these are not the most important
decisions you will make how can that be
how can any decision you will make be
more important than guilt or innocence
then removing the president or not
removing the president I believe the
most important decision in this case is
the one you will make today the most
important question is the question you
must answer today will the president and
the American people get a fair trial
will there be a fair trial I submit that
this is an even more important question
than how you vote on guilt or innocence
because whether we have a fair trial
will determine whether you have a basis
to render a fair and impartial verdict
it is foundational the structure upon
which every other decision you will make
must rest if you only get to see part of
the evidence if you only allow one side
or the other a chance to present their
full case your verdict will be
predetermined by the bias in the
proceeding if the defender is not
allowed to introduce evidence of his
innocence it's not a fair trial so - for
the prosecution if the house cannot call
witnesses or introduce documents and
evidence it's not a fair trial it's not
really a trial at all Americans all over
the country are watching us right now
and imagine they're on grand jury or
they're on jury duty imagine that the
judge walks into that courtroom and says
that she's been talking to the defendant
and at the defendants request the judge
has agreed not to let the prosecution
call any witnesses or introduce any
documents the judge and the defendant
have agreed that the prosecutor may
we read to the jury the dry transcripts
of the grand jury proceedings that's it
has anyone on jury duty in this country
ever heard a judge describes such a
proceeding and call it a fair trial
of course not that's not a fair trial
it's a mockery of a trial under the
Constitution this proceeding the one we
are in right now is the trial this is
not the appeal from a trial you are not
appellate court judges okay one of you
is and unless this trial is going to be
different from every other impeachment
trial or any other kind of trial for
that matter you must allow the
prosecution and defense the house
manager and the president's lawyers to
call relevant witnesses
you must subpoena documents that the
president has blocked but which bear on
his guilt or innocence
you must impartially do justice as your
oath requires so what does a fair trial
look like in the context of impeachment
the short answer is it looks like every
other trial first the resolution should
allow the house managers to obtain
documents that have been withheld first
not last because the documents will
inform the decision about which
witnesses are most important to call and
when the witnesses are called the
documentary evidence will be available
and must be available to question them
with any other order makes no sense
next the resolution should allow the
house managers to call their witnesses
and then the president should be allowed
to do the same and any rebuttal
witnesses and when the evidentiary
portion of the trial ends the parties
argue the case you deliberate and render
a verdict if there's a dispute as to
whether a particular witness is relevant
or material to the charges brought under
the Senate rules the Chief Justice would
rule on the issue of materiality
why should this trial be different than
any other trial the short answer is it
shouldn't the leader McConnell's
resolution would turn the
process on its head his resolution
requires the house to prove its case
without witnesses without documents and
only after it's done will such questions
be entertained with no guarantee that
any witnesses or any documents will be
allowed even then that process makes no
sense so what is the harm of waiting
until the end of the trial of kicking
the can down the road on the question of
documents and witnesses besides the fact
it's completely backwards trial first
then evidence besides the fact that the
documents would inform the decision on
which witnesses and help in their
questioning the harm is this you will
not have any of the evidence the
president continues to conceal
throughout most or all of the trial and
although the evidence against the
president is already overwhelming you
may never know the full scope of the
president's misconduct or those around
him and neither will the American people
the charges here involve the sacrifice
of our national security at home and
abroad and a threat to the integrity of
the next election if there are
additional remedial steps that need to
be taken after the president's
conviction the American people must know
about it but if as a public already
jaded by experience has come to suspect
this resolution is merely the first step
of an effort orchestrated by the White
House to rush the trial hide the
evidence and render a fast verdict or
worse a fast dismissal to make the
president's go away as quickly as
possible to cover up his misdeeds then
the American people will be deprived of
a fair trial and may never learn just
how deep the corruption of this
administration goes or what other risk
to our security and elections remain
hidden the harm will also endure for
this body if the Senate allows the
President to get away with such
extensive obstruction it will affect the
Senate's power of subpoena and oversight
just as much as the house the Senate's
ability to conduct over
I will be beholden to the desires of
this president and future presidents
whether he or she decides they want to
cooperate with a Senate investigation or
another impeachment inquiry and trial
our system of checks and balances will
be broken presidents will become
accountable to no one now it has been
reported that leader McConnell has
already got the votes to pass this
resolution the text of which we did not
see until last night and which has been
changed even moments ago and they say
that leader McConnell is a very good
vote counter nonetheless I hope that
he's wrong and not just because I think
this process the process contemplated by
this resolution is backwards and
designed with the result in mind and
that the result is not a fair trial I
hope that he's wrong because whatever
senators may have said or pledged or
committed has been superseded by an
event of constitutional dimension you
have all now sworn an oath not to each
other not to your legislative leadership
not to the managers or even to the Chief
Justice you have sworn an oath to do
impartial justice that oath binds you
that oath supersedes all else many of
you in the Senate and many of us in the
house have made statements about the
president's conduct or this trial or
this motion or expectations none of that
matters now that is all in the past
nothing matters now but the oath to do
impartial justice and that oath requires
a fair trial fair to the president and
fair to the American people but is that
really possible
or as the founders feared as
factionalism or an excess of
partisanship made that now in
possible one way to find out what a fair
trial should look like devoid of
partisan consideration is to ask
yourselves how would you structure the
trial if you didn't know what your party
was and you didn't know what the party
of the president was what it makes sense
do you'd have that trial first and then
decide on witnesses and evidence later
would that be fair to both sides I have
to think that your answer would be no
let me be blunt let me be very blunt
right now a great many perhaps even most
Americans do not believe there will be a
fair trial they don't believe that the
Senate will be impartial they believe
that the result is precooked the
president will be acquitted not because
he is innocent he is not
but because the centers will vote by
party and he has the votes the votes to
prevent the evidence from coming out the
votes to make sure the public never sees
it the American people want a fair trial
they want to believe their system of
government is still capable of rising to
the occasion they want to believe that
we can rise above party and do what's
best for the country but a great many
Americans don't believe that will happen
let's prove them wrong let's prove them
wrong how by convicting the president no
not by conviction alone by convicting
him if the house proves its case and
only if the house proves its case but by
letting the house prove its case by
letting the house call witnesses by
letting the house obtain documents by
letting the house decide how to present
its own case and not deciding it for us
in sum by agreeing to a fair trial
now let's turn to the precise terms of
the resolution the history of
impeachment trials and what fairness and
impartiality require although we have
many concerns about the resolution I
will begin with its single biggest flaw
the resolution does not ensure that
subpoenas will in fact be issued for
additional evidence that the Senate and
the American people should have and that
the president continues to block to
fairly decide the president's guilt or
innocence moreover it guarantees that
subpoenas will not be issued now when
they would be most valuable to the
Senate the parties and the American
people according to the resolution the
leader has introduced first the Senate
receives briefs and filings from the
parties next adheres lengthy
presentations from the house and the
president now my colleagues the
president's lawyers have described this
as opening statements but let's not kid
ourselves that is the trial that they
contemplate the opening statements are
the trial they'll either be most at the
trial or there'll be all the trial if
the Senate votes to deprive itself of
witnesses and documents the opening
statements will be the end of the trial
so to say let's just have the opening
statements and then we'll see means
let's have the trial and maybe we can
just sweep this all under the rug so
you'll hear these lengthy presentations
from the house there will be a
question-and-answer period for the
Senators and then and only then after
essentially the trial is over after the
briefs have been filed after the
arguments have been made after the
Center's exhaust all their questions
only then will the Senate consider
whether to subpoena crucial documents
and witness testimony that the president
has desperately tried to conceal from
this Congress and the American people
documents and witness testimony that
unlike the Clinton trial have not yet
been seen or heard it is true that the
record compiled by the house is
overwhelming it is true the wreck
already compels the conviction of the
president in the face of unprecedented
inspire house assembled a powerful case
evidence of the president's high crimes
and misdemeanors that includes direct
evidence and testimony of officials who
were unwilling and unwitting in this
scheme and saw it for what it was yet
there was still more evidence relative
and probative evidence that the
continued the president continues to
block that would flesh out the full
extent of the president's misconduct and
those around him we have seen that over
the past few weeks new evidence has
continued to come to light as the
nonpartisan Government Accountability
Office has determined that the hold on
military to Ukraine was illegal and
broke the law as John Bolton has offered
to testify in the trial as one of the
president's agents led Parnas has
produced documentary evidence that
clarifies mr. Giuliani's activities on
behalf of the President and corroborates
ambassador Stalin's testimony that
everyone was in the loop as documents
released under the Freedom of
Information Act have documented the
alarm at the Department of Defense while
the president illegally withheld
military support for Ukraine an ally at
war with Russia without explanation as a
senior Office of Management budget
official Michael Duffy instructed
Defense Department officials on July
25th 90 minutes after President Trump
spoke by phone with President Solinsky
the Defense Department should pause all
obligation of Ukraine military
assistance under its purview 90 minutes
after that call Duffy added quote given
the sensitive nature of the request
I appreciate your keeping that
information closely held to those who
need to know to execute the direction
although the evidence is already more
than sufficient to convict there is
simply no rational basis for the Senate
to deprive itself of all relevant
information
in making such a hugely consequential
judgement moreover as the president's
answer to his summons and his trial
brief made clear the president now
attempts to contest the facts Alby it in
false and misleading ways but the
president should not have it both ways
he should not be permitted to claim that
the facts uncovered by the house are
wrong while also concealing mountains of
evidence that they're precisely on those
facts if this body seeks impartial
justice it should ensure that subpoenas
are issued and that they are issued now
before the Senate begins extended
proceedings based on a record that every
person in this room and every American
watching at home knows does not include
documents and witness testimony it
should because the president would not
allow it to be so complying with these
subpoenas would not impose a burden the
subpoenas cover narrowly tailored and
targeted documents and witnesses that
the president has concealed the Senate
deserves to see the documents from the
White House the State Department the
office of management budget the
Department of Defense these agencies
already should have collected and at
least preserved these documents in
response to House subpoenas indeed in
some cases agencies have already
produced documents in FOIA lawsuits al
biet and heavily redacted form and
witnesses with direct knowledge or
involvement should be heard that
includes the president's acting chief of
staff Mick Mulvaney his former national
security adviser John Bolton who has
publicly offered to testify to senior
officials implementing integral to
implementing the president's freeze on
Ukraine's military aid also have very
relevant testimony why not hear it
Robert Blair who serves as Mulvaney's
senior advisor Michael Duffy a senior
official at OMB and other witnesses with
direct knowledge that we reserve the
right to call later
but these witnesses with whom we wish to
begin the trial last month President Roh
made clear that he supported having
senior officials testifying before the
Senate during his trial declaring that
he would
of to have secretary Pompeo mr. Mulvaney
now former secretary Perry and quote
many other people testify in the Senate
trial the Senate has an opportunity to
take the president up on his offer to
make his senior aides available
including mr. Mulvaney and secretaries
Perry and Pompeyo
but now the president is changing his
tune the bluster of wanting these
witnesses to testify is over
notwithstanding the fact that he has
never asserted a claim of privilege
during the course of the house
impeachment proceedings he threatens to
invoke one now in a last-ditch effort to
keep the rest of the truth from coming
out the president sends his lawyers here
to breathlessly claim that these
witnesses or others cannot possibly
testify because it involves national
security never mind that it was the
president's actions in withholding
military aid from an ally at war that
threatened our national security in the
first place
never mind that the most impossible sir
curity because they will involve other
nations and that misconduct based on
foreign entanglement was what the
framers feared most the presidents
absurdist argument amounts to this we
must endanger national security to
protect national security we must make a
president's conduct threatening our
security beyond the reach of the
Pietschmann power if we are to save the
presidency this is dangerous nonsense as
justices of the Supreme Court have
underscored the Constitution is not a
suicide pact but let us turn from the
abstract to the very concrete and let me
show you just one example of what the
president is hiding in the name of
national security there was a document
which the president has refused to turn
over in which his top diplomat in
Ukraine
says to two other appointees of the
president as I said on the phone I think
it's crazy to withhold security
assistance for help with a political
campaign the administration refuses to
turn over that document and so many more
we only know about its existence we have
only seen its contents because it was
turned over by a cooperating witness
this is what the president would hide
from you and from the American people in
the name of national security he would
hide graphic evidence of his dangerous
misconduct the only question is and it
is the question raised by this
resolution will you let him last year
president Trump said that article 2 of
the Constitution will allow him to do
anything he wanted and evidently
believing that article 2 empowered him
to denigrate and defy a co-equal branch
of government he also declared that he
will fight all subpoenas let's let's
hear the president's own words then I
have an article to where I have the
right to do whatever I want as president
true to his pledge to obstruct Congress
when President Trump faced an
impeachment inquiry and House of
Representatives he ordered the executive
branch to defy every single request on
every single subpoena he issued this
order through his White House Counsel
Pat SIPP alone on October 8 the same
counsel that stood before you a moment
ago to defend the president's misconduct
he then affirmed it again at a rally on
October 10 following president Trump's
catechol categorical order we never
received key documents and
communications it is important to note
in refusing to respond to Congress the
President did not make any any formal
claim of privilege ever instead mr.
sillens letter stated in effect that the
president would would hold all evidence
in the executive branch unless the house
surrendered to demands that would
effectively place
than Trump in charge of the inquiry into
his own misconduct needless to say that
was a non-starter and designed to be so
the president was determined to obstruct
Congress no matter what we did and his
conduct since his attacks on the
impeachment inquiry his attacks on
witnesses have affirmed that the
president never had any intention to
cooperate under any circumstance and why
because the evidence and testimony he
conceals would only further prove his
guilt the innocent do not act this way
simply stated this trial should not
reward the president's obstruction by
allowing him to control what evidence is
seen and when it is seen and what
evidence will remain hidden the
documents the president seeks to conceal
include White House records including
records about the president's unlawful
hold on military aid State Department
records including text messages and
whatsapp messages exchanged by the State
Department and Ukrainian officials and
notes to file written by career
professionals as they saw the present
scheme unfold in real-time
OMB records demonstrating efforts to
fabricate an after-the-fact rationale
for the president's orders and showing
internal objections that the president's
orders violated the law Defense
Department Records reflecting bafflement
an alarm that the president suspended
military aid to a key security partner
without explanation many of the
president's aides have also fault his
orders and refused to testify these
include central figures in the
impeachment inquiry including White
House chief of staff Mick Mulvaney
former national security adviser John
Bolton and many others with relevant
testimony like Robert Blair and Michael
Duffy Mr Blair who serves as a senior
advisor to acting chief of staff
Mulvaney worked directly with mr. Duffy
a political appointee in the Office of
Management and Budget to carry out the
president's order to freeze vital
military and security assistance to
Ukraine the Trump administration has
refused to disclose their communications
even though we know
from written testimony public reporting
and even Freedom of Information Act
lawsuits that they were instrumental in
implementing the hold and extending it
at the presence express direction even
even as career officials warned
accurately that doing so would violate
the law the president has also made the
insupportable claim that the house
should have enforced its subpoenas in
court and allowed the President to delay
his impeachment for years if we had done
so we would have abdicated our
constitutional duty to act on the
overwhelming facts before us and the
evidence the president was seeking to
cheat in the next election we could not
engage in a deliberately protracted
court process while the president
continued to threaten the sanctity of
our elections resorting to the courts is
also inconsistent with a constitution
that gives the house the sole power of
impeachment if the house were compelled
to exhaust all legal remedies before
impeaching the president it would
interpose the courts or the decision of
a single judge between the house and the
power to impeach moreover it would
invite the president to prevent his own
impeachment by endlessly litigating the
matter in court appealing every judgment
engaging in every frivolous motion or
device indeed in the case of Don Magan
the president's lawyer who was ordered
to fire the special counsel and lie
about it he was subpoenaed by the house
in April last year and there is still no
final judgment a president may not
defeat impeachment or accountability by
engaging in endless litigation instead
it's been the long practice of the house
to compile core evidence necessary to
reach a reasoned decision about whether
to impeach and then to bring the case
here to the Senate for a full trial that
is exactly what we did here with an
understanding that the Senate has its
own power to compel documents and
testimony it would be one thing if the
house had shown no interest in documents
or witnesses during its investigation
although even there the house is the
sole right to do
in its proceedings as long as it makes
the full case to the house as it did but
is quite another when the president is
the cause of his own complaint when the
present with holds witnesses and
documents and then attempts to rely on
his own non-compliance to justify
further concealment
President Trump made it crystal clear we
would never see a single document or a
single witness when he declared as we
just watched that he would fight all
subpoenas as a matter of history and
precedent it would be wrong to assert
that the Senate is unable to obtain and
review new evidence during a Senate
trial regardless of why evidence was not
produced in the house you can and should
insist on receiving all the evidence so
you can render impartial justice and can
earn the confidence of the public in the
Senate's willingness to hold a fair
trial under the Constitution the Senate
does not just vote on impeachments it
does not just debate them instead it is
commanded by the Constitution to try all
cases of impeachment if the founders
intended for the house to try the matter
and the Senate to consider an appeal
based on the cold record from the other
chamber they would have said so
but they did not instead they gave us
the power to charge and you the power to
try all impeachments the framers chose
their language and the structure for a
reason as Alexander Hamilton said the
Senate is given awful discretion in
matters of impeachment the Constitution
that speaks to senators in their
judicial character as a court for the
trial of impeachments it requires them
to a gnat aim at real demonstrations of
innocence or guilt and requires them to
do so by holding a trial the Senate is
repeatedly subpoenaed and received new
documents often many of them while
adjudicating cases of impeachment
moreover the Senate has heard witness
testimony in every
of the 15 Senate trials full Senate
trials in the history of this Republic
including those for presidents Andrew
Johnson and Bill Clinton indeed in
President Andrew Johnson Senate
impeachment trial the house managers
were permitted to begin presenting
documentary evidence to the Senate on
the very first day of the trial the
house managers initial presentation of
documents in President Johnson's case
carried on for the first two days of
trial immediately after which witnesses
were called to appear in the Senate this
has been the standard practice in Prior
impeachment trials indeed in most trials
this body has heard from many witnesses
ranging from 3 and Pleasant Clinton's
case to 40 in President Johnson's and
well over 60 in other impeachments as
these numbers make clear the Senate has
always heard from key witnesses when
trying an impeachment the notion that
only evidence that was taken before the
house should be considered is squarely
and unequivocally contrary to Senate
precedent nothing in law or history
supports it to start and consider leader
McConnell's own description of his work
in a prior Senate impeachment proceeding
after serving on the Senate trial
committee in the case of Judge
Clairborne
leader McConnell described how the
Senate committee quote labored
intensively for more than two months
amassing the necessary evidence and
testimony in the same essay leader
McConnell recognized the full body's
responsibility for amassing and
digesting evidence there was certainly a
lot of evidence for the Senate to amass
and digest in that proceeding which
involved charges against a district
court judge the Senate heard testimony
from 19 witnesses and it allowed for
over two thousand pages of documents to
be entered into the record over the
course of that trial at no point did the
Senate limit evidence to what was before
the house it did the opposite consistent
with unbroken Senate practice in every
single impeachment trial every single
one for example of the
40 witnesses who testified during
President Johnson's Senate trial only
three provided testimony to the house
during its impeachment inquiry only
three the remaining 37 witnesses in that
presidential impeachment trial testified
before the Senate Semele similarly the
Senate's full first impeachment trial
which involved charges against judge
Pickering involved testimony from eleven
witnesses all of whom were new to the
impeachment proceedings and not had not
testified before the house there are
many other examples of this point
including the Senate's most recent
impeachment trial of Judge Porteous in
2010 it is one that many of you and some
of us know well it too is consistent
with this long-standing practice there
the Senate heard testimony from 26
witnesses
17 of whom had not testified before the
House during its impeachment inquiry
thus there is a definitive tradition of
the Senate hearing from new witnesses
when trying articles of impeachment
there has never been a rule omitting
witnesses to those appeared in the house
or limiting evidence before the Senate
to that which the house itself
considered and that is because a senator
Hiram Johnson explained in 1934 the
integrity of Senate impeachment trials
depend heavily upon the witnesses who
are called they were appearance on the
stand their mode of giving testimony
there is thus an unbroken history of
witness testimony and Senate impeachment
trials presidential and judicial I would
argue in the case of a president it is
even more important to hear the
witnesses and see the documents any
conceivable doubt on this score and
there should be none left is dispelled
by the Senate's own rules for trial of
impeachment obtaining documents and
hearing live witness testimony is so
fundamental that the rules of procedure
and practice in the Senate when sitting
on a beach Minh trials which date back
to the 19th century devote more
attention to the gathering handling and
mission of new evidence than any other
single subject these rules expressly
to plate that the Senate will hear
evidence and conduct a thorough trial
when sitting as a court of impeachment
at every turn they reject the notion
that the Senate would take the house's
evidentiary record blind itself to
everything else and vote to convict or
acquit
for example rule 6 says the Senate shall
have the power to compel the attendance
of witnesses and enforce obedience to
its orders rule 7 authorizes the
presiding officer to rule in all
questions of evidence including but not
limited to questions of relevancy
materiality and redundancy this rule too
presumes that the Senate trial will have
testimony giving rise to such questions
rule 11 authorizes the full Senate to
designate a committee of senators to
receive evidence and take testimony at
such times in places as the committee
may determine as rule 11 makes clear the
committee's report must be transmitted
to the full Senate for final
adjudication but nothing herein the rule
states shall prevent the Senate from
sending for any witness and hearing his
testimony in open Senate or by order of
the Senate involving the entire trial in
the open center here to the Senate's
operative impeachment rules expressly
contemplate and provide for subpoenaing
witnesses and hearing their testimony as
part of the Senate trial and the list
goes on these rules plainly contemplate
a robust role for the Senate in
gathering and considering evidence they
reflect centuries of practice of
accepting and requiring new evidence in
Senate trials this Senate should honor
that practice today by rejecting this
resolution
what about the Clinton trial what about
the Clinton trial it will be argued even
if we are departing from every other
impeachment trial in history including
the president impeachment of President
Andrew Johnson what about the Clinton
trial are we following the same
processes in the Clinton trial the
answer is no first the process for the
Clinton trial was worked out by mutual
consent among the parties that is not
true here where the process is sought to
be imposed by one party on the other
second all of the documents in the
Clinton trial were turned over prior to
the trial all 90,000 pages of them so
they could be used in the houses case
none of the documents have been turned
over by the president in this case and
under leader McConnell's proposal none
may ever be they certainly won't be
available to you or to us during most or
all of the trial if we are really going
to follow the Clinton precedent the
Senate must insist on the documents now
before the trial begins
third the issue in the Clinton trial was
not one of calling witnesses but of
recalling witnesses all the key
witnesses in the Clinton trial had
testified before the grand jury or been
interviewed by the FBI one of them
dozens of times and their testimony was
already known President Clinton himself
testified on camera and under oath
before the Senate trial he allowed
multiple chiefs of staff and other key
officials to testify again before the
Senate trial took place here none of the
witnesses we seek to call none of them
have testified or been interviewed by
the house and as I said the president
cannot complain that we did not call
these witnesses before the house when
their unavailability was caused by the
President himself and last
as you will remember those of you that
were here the testimony in the Clinton
trial involved decorum issues that are
not present here you may rest assured
whatever else the case may be such
issues will not be present here in some
the Clinton press event if you're
serious about if we're really serious
about modeling this proceeding after the
Clinton trial the Clinton precedent is
one where all the documents had been
provided up front where all the
witnesses had testified upfront prior to
the trial that is not being replicated
by the McConnell resolution not in any
way not in any shape not in any form far
from it
the traditional model followed in
President Johnson's case and all of the
others is really the one that's most
appropriate to the circumstances the
Senate should address all the
documentary issues and most of the
wishes witness is now not later the need
to subpoena documents and testimony now
has only increased due to the
president's obstruction for several
reasons first his obstruction has made
him uniquely and personally responsible
for the absences of the witnesses before
the house having ordered them not to
appear he may not be heard to complain
now that they followed his orders and
refused to testify to do otherwise only
rewards the president's obstruction and
encourages further future presence to
defy lawful process in impeachment
investigations second if the president
wishes to contest the facts and his
answer and trial brief indicates that he
will try he must not continue to deny
the Senate access to the relevant
witnesses and documents that shed light
on the very factual matters he wishes to
challenge the Senate trial is not
analogous to an appeal where the parties
must argue the facts on the basis of the
record below there is no record below
there is no blow this is the trial
third the
must not be allowed to mislead the
Senate by selectively introducing
documents while withholding the vast
body of documents that may contradict
this is very important the president
must not be allowed to mislead you by
introducing documents selectively and
withholding all of the rest all of the
relevant documents should be produced or
there is full disclosure of the truth
otherwise there is a clear risk that the
president will continue to hide all
evidence harmful to his position while
selectively producing documents without
any context or opportunity to examine
their creators and finally you may infer
the president's guilt from his
continuing efforts to obstruct
production of documents and witnesses
the president has said he wants
witnesses like Mulvaney and Pompeyo and
others to testify and that his
interactions with Ukraine have been
perfect counsel has affirmed today that
will be the president's defense his
conduct was perfect it's perfect
perfectly fine to coerce an ally by
withholding military aid to get help
cheating in the next election that will
be part of the president's defense
although lb it not worded in that way
but now he has changed course and does
not want these witnesses to testify the
logical inference in any court of law
would be that the parties continued
obstruction of lawful subpoenas may be
construed as evidence of guilt let me
conclude the facts will come out in the
end the documents which the president is
hiding will be released through the
Freedom of Information Act or through
other means over time witnesses will
tell their stories in books and film the
truth will come out the question is will
it come out in time and what answer
shall we give if we did not pursue the
truth now and let it remain hidden until
it was too late to consider on the
profound issue of the president's guilt
or innocence
there are many overlapping reasons for
voting against this resolution but they
all converge on a single idea fairness
the trial should be fair to the house
which has been wrongly deprived of
evidence by a president who wishes to
conceal it it should be fair to the
president who will not benefit from an
acquittal or dismissal if the trial is
not viewed as fair if it is not viewed
as impartial and fair to you senators
who are tasked with the grave
responsibility of determining whether to
convict or acquit and should do so with
the benefit of all of the facts and fair
to the American people who deserve the
full truth and who deserve
representatives who will seek it on
their behalf and with that mr. Chief
Justice I yield back mr. sip Loney mr.
Sekulow you have 57 minutes available
[Music]
Thank You mr. Chief Justice members of
the Senate leader McConnell Democratic
leader Schumer it's also my privilege to
represent the President of the United
States before this chamber Senator
Schumer said earlier today that the eyes
of the founders are on these proceedings
Adeem that's true but it's the heart of
the Constitution that governs these
proceedings and what we just heard from
managership courts have no role
privileges don't apply what happened in
the past we should just ignore in fact
managership just said try to summarize
my colleagues defense of the president
he said not in those words of course
which is not the first time mr. Schiff
has put words
into transcripts that did not exist mr
shipp also talked about a trifecta I'll
give you a trifecta during the
proceedings that took place before the
Judiciary Committee the president was
denied the right to cross-examine
witnesses the president was denied the
right to access evidence and the
president was denied the right to have
counsel present at hearings that's a
trifecta a trifecta that violates the
Constitution of the United States mr.
Schiff did say the courts really don't
have a role in this executive privilege
why would that matter it matters because
it's based in the Constitution of the
United States one manager said that it
is you that are on trial the Senate he
also said that and others did that
you're not capable of abiding by your
oath and then we had the invocation of
the ghosts of the Muller report I know
something about that report it came up
empty on the issue of collusion with
Russia
there was no obstruction in fact the
Muller report to the contrary what these
managers say today came to the exact
opposite conclusions of what they say
let me quote from the house impeachment
report at page 16 although President
Trump has in times invoked the notion of
due process an impeachment trial and
appeasement inquiry is not a criminal
trial and should not be confused with it
believe me what has taken place in these
proceedings is not to be confused with
due process because due process demands
and the Constitution requires that
fundamental fairness and due process
wearing a lot about due process due
process is designed to protect the
person accused
when the Russia investigation failed it
devolved into the Ukraine a quid pro quo
with that didn't prove out it was then
bribery or maybe extortion if somebody
said one of the members or the members
of the House said treason but instead we
get two articles of impeachment two
articles of impeachment that have a
vague allegation about an on crime
allegation of abuse of power and
obstruction of Congress members managers
right here before you today who have
said that executive privilege and
constitutional privileges have no place
in these proceedings On June 28 2012
Attorney General Eric Holder became the
first United States Attorney General to
be held in both civil and criminal
contempt why because President Obama
started executive privilege with respect
to the holder contempt proceedings mr.
managership
wrote the White House assertion of
privilege is backed by decades of
precedent that has recognized the need
for the president and his senior
advisors to receive candid advice and
information from their top aides indeed
that's correct
not because managership said it but
because the Constitution requires it mr.
manager Nadler said that the effort to
hold Eric Holder Attorney General Holder
in contempt for refusing to comply with
various subpoenas was quote politically
motivated and speaker Pelosi called the
hold of matter and I quote more than a
little more than a witch-hunt what are
we dealing with here why are we here are
we here because of a phone call or are
we here before this great body
cause since the president was sworn into
office there was a desire to see him
removed I remember in the model report
there were discussions about remember
insurance policies the insurance policy
did work out so well
so then we moved to other investigations
I guess you would call it reinsurance or
an umbrella policy and that didn't work
out so well and here we are today
managership quoted the Supreme Court and
I'd like to make reference to the
Supreme Court as well
it was then justice Rehnquist later to
be Chief Justice Rehnquist who wrote
from the majority in the United States
versus Russell in 1973 these are the
words we may someday be presented with
the situation which the conduct of law
enforcement agents is so outrageous the
due process principles would absolutely
bar the government from invoking
judicial process to obtain a eviction
that day is today that day was a year
ago that day was in July when Special
Counsel Muller testified I am NOT today
going to take the time to review what I
will do it later the pattern and
practices of irregularities that have
gone on in these investigations from the
outset but to say that the courts have
no role the rush to impeachment to not
wait for a decision from a court on an
issue as important as executive
privilege as if executive privilege
hasn't been utilized by presidents since
our founding this is not some new
concept we don't waive executive
privilege and there's a reason we
keep executive privilege and we asserted
when necessary and that is to protect to
protect the Constitution and the
separation of powers the president's
opponents in their rush to impeach have
refused to wait for complete judicial
review that was their choice
speaker Pelosi clearly expressed her
impatience and contempt for judicial
preachings when she said we cannot be at
the mercy of the courts think about that
for a moment we cannot be at the mercy
of the courts
so take article three of the United
States Constitution remove it we're
acting as if the courts are an improper
venue to determine constitutional issues
of this magnitude that is why we have
courts that is why we have a federal
judiciary
it was interesting when Professor Turley
testified before the House Judiciary
Committee in front of mr. Nadler
committee he said we have three branches
of government not two if you impeach a
president if you make a high crime and
misdemeanor out of going to courts and
abuse of power it's your abuse of power
you know it's more than that a lot more
than that there's a lot more than an
abuse of power if you say the courts
don't apply constitutional principles
don't apply let's start with a clean
slate as if nothing happened
a lot has happened as we proceed in the
days of head we will lay out our case
we're gonna put forward to the American
people but more important for the
Constitution's sake what's taking place
here but this idea
that we should ignore what has taken
place over the last three years is
outrageous we believe that Senator
McConnell has put forward provides due
process allows the proceedings to move
forward in an orderly fashion 33 days 33
days they held on to those in
Pietschmann
articles 33 days it was such a rush of
national security that impedes this
president before Christmas that they
then held them for 33 days to do what to
act as if they negotiate the House of
Representatives should negotiate the
rules of the United States Senate they
didn't hide this
this was the express purpose this was
the reason they did it we're prepared to
proceed majority leader Democratic
majority leader we're prepared to
proceed in our view these proceedings
should begin the rest of my time to my
colleague Boyd house counsel Thank You
mr. chief justice
I just want to make a couple of
additional points it's very difficult to
sit there and listen to mr. Schiff tell
the tale that he just told let's
remember how we all got here they made
false allegations about a telephone call
the President of the United States
Declassified that telephone call and
released it to the public
how's that for transparency when mr.
Schiff found out that there were not
there was nothing to his allegations he
focused on the second telephone call he
made false and his colleagues made false
allegations about that second telephone
call that occurred before the one he had
demanded so the President of the United
States
Declassified and released that telephone
call still nothing again complete
transparency in a way that frankly I'm
unfamiliar with any precedent of any
President of the United States releasing
a classified telephone call with a
foreign leader when mr. Schiff saw that
his allegations were false and he knew
it anyway what did he do he went to the
house and he manufactured a fraudulent
version of that call he manufactured a
false version of that call he read it to
the American people and he didn't tell
them it was a complete fake do you want
to know about due process I'll tell you
about due process never before in the
history of our country has a president
been confronted with this kind of
impeachment proceeding in the house
it wasn't conducted by the Judiciary
Committee now mr. Nadler when he applied
for that job told his colleagues when
they took over the house that he was
really good at impeachment but what
happened was the proceedings took place
in a basement of the House of
Representatives the president was
forbidden from attending the president
was not allowed to have a lawyer present
in every other impeachment proceeding
the president has been given a minimal
of minimal due process nothing here not
even mr. shifts Republican colleagues
were allowed into the skiff information
was selectively leaked out witnesses
were threatened good public servants
were told that they would be held in
contempt they were told that they were
in obstructing what is mr. Schiff mean
by obstructing he
means that unless you do exactly what he
says regardless of your constitutional
rights than you're obstructing the
president was not allowed to call
witnesses by the way there's still
evidence in the skiff that we haven't
been allowed to see I wonder why no
witnesses now let's let's think about
something else for a second let's think
about something else
they held these articles for 33 days we
hear all this talk about an overwhelming
case an overwhelming case that they're
not even prepared today to stand up and
make an opening argument about that's
because they have no case frankly they
have no charge when you look at these
articles of impeachment they're not only
ridiculous they are dangerous to our
republic and why first of all the notion
that invoking your constitutional rights
to protect the executive branch that's
been done by just about every president
since George Washington that that is
obstruction that is our patriotic duty
mr. Schiff particularly when confronted
with a wholesale trampling of
constitutional rights that I'm
unfamiliar with in this country frankly
it's the kind of thing that our State
Department would criticize if we see it
in foreign countries we've never seen
anything like it
and mr. Schiff said have I got a deal
for you abandon all your constitutional
rights
forget about your lawyers and come in
and do exactly what I say
no thank you no thank you and then he
says he has the temerity to come into
the Senate and say we have no use for
courts it's outrageous
now let me tell you another story
there's a man named Charlie Kupperman he
is the deputy national security adviser
he is the number two to john bolton
because you have to remember mr. Schiff
wants you to forget but you have to
remember how we got here they threatened
him they sent him a subpoena mr.
Cooperman did what any American should
be allowed to do used to be allowed to
do he was forced to get a lawyer he was
forced to pay for that lawyer and he
went to court mr. Schiff doesn't like
courts he went to court and he said
judge tell me what to do I have
obligations that frankly rise to the
what the Supreme Court has called the
apex of executive privilege in the area
of national security and then I have a
subpoena from mr. Schiff what do I do
you know what mr. Schiff dead did mr.
Cooperman went to the judge and the
house said never mind we withdraw the
subpoena we promise not to issue it
again and then they come here and they
ask you to do the work that they refuse
to do for themselves they ask you to
trample on executive privilege now would
they ever suggest that the executive
could determine on its own what the
speech or debate Clause means of course
not would they ever suggest that the
house could invade the discussions that
the Supreme Court has behind closed
doors I hope not
but they come here and they ask you to
do what they refuse to do for themselves
they had a court date and they withdrew
the subpoena they evaded a decision and
they're asking you to become complicit
in that evasion of the courts it's
ridiculous and we should call it out for
what it is obstruction for going to
court it's an act of patriotism to
defend the constitutional rights of the
president because if they can do it to
the president they could do it to any of
you and they could do it to any American
citizen and that's wrong and Lawrence
tribe who's been advising them I guess
he didn't tell you that in the Clinton
impeachment he said it's dangerous to
suggest that invoking constitutional
rights is impeachable it's dangerous and
you know what it is dangerous mr. Schiff
so what are we doing here we have the
house that completely concocted a
process that we've never seen before
they lock the president out oh and by
the way will mr. Schiff give documents
we asked him for documents we asked him
for documents when contrary to his prior
statements it turned out that his staff
was working with the whistleblower we
said let us see the documents release
them to the public
we're still waiting so the idea that
they would come here and lecture the
Senate by the way I was surprised to
hear that
did you realize you're on trial mr.
Nadler is putting you on trial
everybody's on trial except for them
it's ridiculous it's ridiculous
they said in their brief we have
overwhelming evidence and they're afraid
to make
their case think about it think about it
it's common sense overwhelming evidence
to impeach the President of the United
States and then they come here on the
first day and they say you know what we
need some more evidence now let me tell
you something if I showed up in any
court in this country and I said Judge
my case is overwhelming but I'm not
ready to go yet I need more evidence
before I can make my case I would get
thrown out in two seconds and that's
exactly what should happen here that's
exactly what should happen here it's too
much to listen to almost the hypocrisy
of the whole thing and what are the
stakes what are the stakes
there's an election in almost nine
months months from now there's going to
be an election senators in this body the
last time had very wise words they
echoed the words of our founders a
partisan impeachment is like stealing an
election and that's exactly what we have
we have talked about the framers worst
nightmare
it's a partisan impeachment that they've
delivered to your doorstep in an
election year some of you are upset
because you should be in Iowa right now
but instead we're here and they're not
ready to go and it's outrageous it's
outrageous and the American people won't
stand for it I'll tell you that right
now
they're not here to steal one election
they're here to steal two elections it's
buried in the small print of their
ridiculous articles of impeachment they
want to remove the President Trump from
the ballot they won't tell you that they
don't have the guts to say it directly
but that's exactly what they're here to
do they're asking this
Senate to attack one of the most sacred
rights we have as American Americans the
right to choose our president in an
election year it's never been done
before it shouldn't be done with it now
the reason it's never been done is
because no one ever thought that it
would be a good idea for our country for
our children for our grandchildren
to try to remove a president from a
ballot to deny the American people the
right to vote based on a fraudulent
investigation conducted in secret with
no rights well I could go on and on but
my point is very simple it's long past
time that we start this so we can end
this ridiculous charade and go have an
election thank you very much mr. Chief
Justice does
council yield back the remainder of
their time thank you
the Democratic leader is recognized mr.
chief justice
I send an amendment to the desk to
subpoena certain documents and records
from the White House and I ask that it
be read the clerk will read the document
the senator from New York mr. Schumer
proposes an amendment number 12 84 at
the appropriate place in the resolving
clause insert the following section
notwithstanding any other provision of
this resolution pursuant to rules 5 and
6 of the rules and procedure and
practice in the Senate when sitting on
impeachment trials one the Chief Justice
of the United States through the
Secretary of the Senate shall issue a
subpoena to the acting chief of staff of
the White House commanding him to
produce for the time period from January
1st 2019 to the present all documents
communications and other records within
the possession custody or control of the
White House including the National
Security Council referring or relating
to a all meetings and calls between
President Trump and the president of
Ukraine including documents
communications and other records related
to the scheduling of preparation for and
follow-up from the president's April
21st in July 25th 2019 telephone calls
as well as the president's September
25th 2019 meeting with the president of
Ukraine in New York be all
investigations enquiries or other probes
relating to Ukraine including any that
relate in any way to one former vice
president Joseph Biden to Hunter Biden
and any of his associates three burries
ma holdings limited also known as
Purisima for interference or involvement
by Ukraine in the 2016 United States
election five the Democratic National
Committee or six CrowdStrike
see the actual or potential suspension
withholding delaying freezing or
releasing of United States foreign
assistance military assistance or
security assistance of any kind to
Ukraine including but not limited to the
Ukraine Security Assistance initiative
USA I and foreign military financing ffd
all documents communications
notes and other records created or
received by acting chief of staff Mick
Mulvaney then National Security Advisor
John R Bolton senior adviser to the
chief of staff Robert B Blair and other
White House officials relating to
efforts to one solicit request demand
induce persuade or coerce Ukraine to
conduct or announce investigations to
offers scheduled cancel or withhold a
White House meeting for Ukraine's
president or three hold and then release
military and other security assistance
to Ukraine II meetings at or involving
the White House that related to Ukraine
including but not limited to one
president zelinsky's inauguration on May
20th 2019 in Kiev Ukraine including but
not limited to president Trump's
decision to not to attend to ask vice
president pence to lead the delegation
directing vice president pence not to
attend and subsequent decision about the
composition of the delegation of the
United States to a meeting at the White
House on or around May 23rd 2019
involving among others president Trump
then Special Representative for Ukraine
negotiations ambassador Kurt Volker then
Energy Secretary Rick Perry and United
States ambassador to the European Union
Gordon Sundlun as well as any private
meetings or conversations with those
individuals before or after the larger
meeting three meetings at the White
House on or about July 10th 2019
involving Ukrainian officials Andrew
your Mac and Ola skander Daniel UNK and
United States government officials
including but not limited to then
National Security Advisor John Bolton
secretary Perry ambassador Volcker
ambassador sunland to include at least a
meeting in ambassador Bolton's office
and subsequent meeting in the wardroom
for a meeting at the White House on or
around August 30th 2019 involving
President Trump Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo and Secretary of Defense
Mark Esper five a plan meeting later
canceled in Warsaw Poland on or around
September 1st 2019 between President
Trump and president zalenski and
subsequently attended by Vice President
Pence and six a meeting at the White
House on or around September 11 2009
teen involving President Trump vice
president pence and mr. Mulvaney
concerning the lifting of the hold on
security assistance for Ukraine meetings
telephone calls or conversations related
to any occasions in which the National
Security Council officials reported
concerns to National Security Council
lawyers including but not limited to
National Security Council legal adviser
John Eisenberg regarding matters related
to Ukraine including but not limited to
one the decision to delay military
assistance to Ukraine to the July 10th
2019 meetings at the White House with
Ukrainian officials three the
president's July 25th 2019 call with the
president of Ukraine for a September 1st
2019 meeting between ambassador Sandlin
and a Ukrainian official and five
presidents September 7 2019 call with
Ambassador sunland G any internal view
or assessment within the White House
regarding Ukraine matters following the
September 9th 2019 request for documents
from the house permanent Select
Committee on Intelligence the House
Committee on Oversight and Reform and
the House Committee on Foreign Affairs
including but not limited to documents
collected that pertain to the hold on
military and other security assistance
to Ukraine the scheduling of a White
House meeting for the president of
Ukraine and any requests for
investigations by Ukraine H the
complaint submitted by a whistleblower
within the intelligence community on or
around August 12 2019 - the Inspector
General of the intelligence community I
all mean
or calls including requests for or
recordings of meetings or telephone
calls scheduling items calendar entries
White House visitor records and email or
text messages using personal or work
related devices between or among one
current or former White House officials
or employees including but not limited
to President Trump and to Rudolph W
Giuliani ambassador Sunland Victoria tun
sting or Joseph digenova and J former
United States Ambassador to Ukraine
Murray Masha
Jovanovic including but not limited to
the decision to end her tour or recall
her from the United States Embassy in
Kiev and to the sergeant-at-arms is
authorized to utilize the services of
the deputy sergeant at arms or any other
employee of the United States Senate in
serving the subpoena authorized to be
issued by this section mr. Chief Justice
the majority leader is recognized and I
ask for a brief 15-minute recess before
the parties are recognized to debate the
Schumer Amendment there for eyes consent
the Senate stand in recess subject to
the call of the chair without objection
so ordered
[Music]
[Music]
personally tremendously disappointed in
terms of the Association we had and the
fact that we didn't get out of that
relationship earlier but I'm thankful
that we're getting out of it now we're
taking the actions and we'll wait for
the investigation to continue there's an
orchestrated attack by the current
government that is completely
politically motivated my holdings are
commercial there are no proceeds from
contracts or public contracts or money
that have been deviated from public
funds
[Music]